- "BEEN TRYING TO REACH OUT
TO YOU ALL DAY.
ARE WE ON FOR TONIGHT?"
[sighs]
JEEZ.
- WHAT?
YOU CAN'T CATCH ME.
I'M LANCE MOORE.
TOUCHDOWN, BITCH.
WHAT?
PAUSE.
[phone chimes]
OH, SHOOT.
KEEGAN'S BEEN TEXTING ME.
"SORRY, DUDE,
MISSED YOUR TEXTS.
"I ASSUMED WE'D MEET AT THE BAR.
WHATEVER.
I DON'T CARE."
[phone chimes]
- "SORRY, DUDE,
MISSED YOUR TEXTS.
"I ASSUMED WE'D MEET AT THE BAR.
WHATEVER.
I DON'T CARE."
"WHATEVER. I DON'T CARE"?
WHAT THE FUCK IS HIS PROBLEM?
"DO YOU EVEN WANT TO HANG OUT?"
- "DO YOU EVEN WANT
TO HANG OUT?"
OH, THAT'S CONSIDERATE.
"LIKE I SAID, WHATEVER."
- "LIKE I SAID, WHATEVER"?
FUCK THIS GUY.
JESUS, "YOU..."
- "ARE FUCKING PRICELESS."
AWW.
"YOU'RE THE..."
- "ONE WHO'S FUCKING PRICELESS"?
THIS M--
THIS MOTHERFUCKER HERE.
OH, HE WANTS TO--
OKAY, MM-HMM.
MM-HMM.
OKAY.
"YOU WANT TO GO..."
- "RIGHT NOW?"
HMM.
GUESS I COULD DO THAT.
[clears throat]
"OKAY..."
- "OKAY, LET'S GO"?
HE SAID OKA--
"OKAY, LET'S GO"?
ALL RIGHT, YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
"YOU WANT TO REALLY..."
- "DO THIS NOW?"
KEEGAN, YOU NUT.
YOU'RE NOT PUTTING ME OUT.
- "FUCK YEAH, LET'S DO IT"?
OH, YOU FUCKING ASSHOLE!
- "FIRST ROUND'S MINE."
- OH, NO!
OH, NO!
THERE AIN'T GONNA BE
NO ROUNDS, ASSHOLE!
IT'S GONNA BE
A FUCKING STREET FIGHT!
THIS SON OF A--
- ♪ 'CAUSE TONIGHT WE GONNA
PARTY AND THE PARTY DON'T STOP ♪
- YOU!
- BUDDY!
LIKE I SAID, FIRST ROUND'S MINE.
A BEER AND A GIMLET
FOR MY PARTNER RIGHT--
WHAT'S THAT?
- UH, I-I GOT YOU
A BASEBALL BAT WITH NAILS IN IT.
- FOR MY POST-APOCALYPTIC
JACKIE ROBINSON COSTUME.
HOW DID YOU KNOW?